do Ryan right hey oh good this bit my
salon has down syndrom that's how I do
my impressionist alone or though
Stallone that wasn't just a [ __ ]
child no okay
hello I'm Javik away Luther no no that's
how you doing dude - anyway we're gonna
watch from CollegeHumor great sketch
channel if rocky for happened for real
30 for 30 parody don't know what the 30
for 30 means but rocky for um best rocky
movie of all time
hands-down never seen a rocky movie as
good as rocky for that was except for
rocky 5 just to clarify I was joking
I don't think rocky 4 is the best rocky
it's actually one of the worst ones it
wouldn't surprise me if you thought that
was the Busby it's not the bests I
thought rocky 5 was the best growing up
I thought it was the best - with all the
hip-hop music and then I got older and
realized this is the worst one of the
moment
it's just a company oh this is boring
like they're a basic level Mirza you
dissing for Israel
it's a squat I feel a lot of change
support ricotta with air my granny is
really diversified and they leave the
turo stealth a brilliant student
accounts
I have been naturally thin blade yeah
that's how it's like get out some like
in the movie
yeah like what I messed up country this
is gonna be the heads the comer so it's
1985 which is three years after Balboa
Lange to which at the time was the most
watched fight in u.s. boxing history
from a political standpoint that was
tenses ever in the sports world US and
the Soviet they really hated each other
memories are still fresh of the Olympic
upset in 1980 and surely the Soviets
wanted revenge in comes a von Drago
Drago is the kind of embodiment of the
Soviet you half a machine and you wonder
if he has a soul in there somewhere and
Apollo Creed is the embodiment of
America now I've followed boxing and
danced for 23 years Apollo Creed was in
dance shape not boxing shape Creed is
clearly exhausted by the dance number he
didn't James Brown five minutes round is
over that's it this was very good let
the American public to see I've only
cried twice because of a sporting event
when happy gilmore accidentally killed
chubbs and then it's the same guy white
Dave been set yet December twenty-fifth
see Russian I interviewed Rakhi about
that time in 84 he was retired he just
wanted to spend time at home with his
family
there's robot hahaha I was so random
can't biggest TV event of a decade
second only to the National Pashtun now
awesome
this was not just the focal point of the
fight world on that night this was the
focal point of the world
rocky learned from creed and decided not
to do it 20 minute dance number
boy in the first round Rocky was just
outmatched I mean this was a fun guy
these guys landed 91 percent of their
power punches that's unheard of
uh yeah barely resemble boxing I've been
cover boxing a lot but I never see
anything like this these guys would
punch each other way after the bell
sounded they wrestle each other who fit
through each other across the ring the
corner men were fighting each other
Drago picked up his promoted by the neck
from a technical standpoint it's the
worst defense I've ever seen in a boxing
yeah hard these guys would punch it's
everything I thought it even land but to
hit foo back anyway like from the air or
something I have covered sports for 35
years and I have never seen a home crowd
switch sides
[Music]
crowd switch sides and started booing
for Rocky that wasn't of our system
fearless [ __ ] passion commitment I
don't know never really made sense to me
because the rocky spierig erotic I don't
have a good answer for that
rocky lands an amazing combination of
punches and just like their history was
made
in here due to guys showing each other
that's better
- and who could have predicted that this
relatively inarticulate rambling at the
end of a boxing match we're building
some Lucknow most important speeches
20th century I think it always bothered
Rocky that he never received much credit
for his role in ending the Cold War
Reagan never once thanked him and I
think that's part of the reason that he
faded from the spotlight I just hope I
did yes my believe did to me seen you
this night from a mission
[Music]
so random
thanks for watching click here to
subscribe to college humor and here to
watch more videos where you can catch
all the last well I did that's pretty
[ __ ] accurate that's when you're
watching you're immersed in it you're
not thinking about all the surrounding
now I sighed 2 days ago I've been
watching all them again yeah but you're
not watching it in context like you got
at the time that the movie came out it
made sense because we were afraid of the
Cold War
have you seen em get robots ok I thought
the rocky franchise lost all sense of
reality when rocky fought Hulk Hogan and
part three they have a wrestling match
that was that was a charity organization
yeah but he is like [ __ ] the hell out
of rocky and rocky just keeps getting
back up as if like there's no injury the
Italian stallion oh you cannot defend
that there's no sense of reality after
that [ __ ] paulie getting the robot
mm-hmm what that was realistic he was
riding to the light he's a wealthy guy
no seriously he's a wealthy guy he could
have anything in the world
paulie's what I mean paulie's paulie's a
weird guy wait what did colleague did
Paulie give him the robot or no no rocky
gave Paulie the robot that makes perfect
sense what where did you get the robot
it was a gift I mean it was they sell
those robots in the 80s they had mr. the
mr. robot toy for Nintendo that's just
an extension of that we were obsessed
with robots Robocop the rocky sci-fi
picture I have the guy who looks like
wall-e the big one I think you're just
trying to piss me off right now I think
no I hated it I felt rocky for was awful
there's one montage right I count three
full montages in that film yeah one
montage where Rocky's like all upset
over foot I know something the Rocky
movies there's always someone who has to
tell rocky you can't do it and it was
Adrian in that he takes off in the car
montage of all the other rocky films the
only memories Rocky has of Apollo our
footage from the last three Rocky films
II have no friendship outside of it
getting a shot like some extra footage
for the movie right which rocky was it
where he was showering at the beginning
and he was all messed up from the last
five that was Rocky five five takes
place like immediately after the boxing
match afore that was the only good scene
in that movie was the opening Mikey
you know how that makes you sound what
you just said the only good scene is
when Rocky is showering at the opening
you know all right not because he's
showering not because he's naked but
because you've seen he's vulnerable his
hands were shaking and stuff yeah he's
like has brain trauma in that one right
but the other montage is okay Rocky goes
to Russia trains and you see Drago
training too and then Adrian shows up
and she's like you know what I changed
my mind I'm here to support you
rocky just has another montage
immediately after of him doing even more
wordy now but he's slightly improved
since Adrian's there now the wrong with
the Rocky movies that he came so villain
heavy with three and four and five - you
didn't enjoy that running scene on the
beach with Creed when there in the short
run I did that was hilarious
cuz the first there running in there
spinner zooming down their quads I was
like alright a little gay whatever but
then once they jump in the water and
start hugging each other so I'm like
they went all out with this whole new
level that was acceptable in the 80s and
it wasn't gay now now it's awkward my
gays more acceptable is that weird
that is interesting it's like now we
have more percent we have we perceived
more things as gay ish but we're more
accepting of the gap the gays and as far
as the the matches go I don't know why
Rocky never learned to puck to block
like never ever got blocking a punch
down he's always there hands wide open
just doing the bob but it leaves his
head wide open and I love how in this
video they pointed out like it's the
worst form of defense ever in the Rocky
movies they end up punching each other
so much that you're like I never see
that in a real boxing man yeah but the
thing is you see in his head trauma in
the next movie
stop stop it just stop stop just doesn't
that doesn't that fix it doesn't that
fix the problem well no the problem is
rocky never learn to block and I don't
get how you could stay standing the
whole time it's fun it's entertain I
will say I like Dolph Lundgren
at Dolph Lundgren if you watch um toke
little little dragon in Tokyo or
something like Dragon in Little Tokyo
shadow a little brand only right only
that one whatever it's called there's a
scene when Dolph Lundgren jumps over a
car and you can see the thing launch him
into the air oh really yeah it's kind of
amazing
I like his performance I think he I
think he did a good level subtlety to it
it wasn't like an over-the-top Russian
character he barely spoke in the movie
he barely spoke with the body language
and facial expressions he had down work
was menacing like he was a intimidating
guy more than just the size when pretty
eyes he's like oh well whose Creed's
manager I don't remember the black guy
who's always like don't do it quick like
every every Rocky movie he's crying in
the corner Oh in the towel it's
emotional it's very emotional intense
and when Creed died that was that was
pretty heartbreaking even that was
pretty predictable
was it predictable was it pretty easily
was gonna die it was a predictable
because they killed the old man and
three it's predictable because it's a
boxing match early on in the movie and
Rocky's not fighting the main it could
have just lost he could have been into
went into a coma it seems like every
rocky film kills off someone else yeah
Rocky five didn't kill off anyone killed
off Rocky
no he came back 20 years later sure
Thank You Olaf a drink yeah and then
Pauly's dead no paulie's alive in the
last ones Creed right paulie's daddy and
Creed I thought he was uh I haven't seen
the movie yet
Rocky's just gonna be very alone for the
rest of his life whatever han left and
now he's dying and passing the torch to
Creed's son anyway guys thanks for
tuning into the channel if you're new to
it subscribe today and become a reject
ah just can't get over saying that um
whatever you've seen extras no oh are
you having a real fucked-up moment here
I didn't realize that okay an extra is
he gets a catchphrase and he hates the
catchphrase because he thinks
catchphrases are cheap gimmicks oh yeah
and my pet catchphrases help close it
out people like catchphrases right yeah
they like they like to see the same
beginning same end well that's when we
get studio movies but that mean that
makes people feel comfortable
anyway become a reject yeah you have a
title now and you could check out jabby
Kuwait on the G
a beak away channel face it yes Jen like
20 years I still epic away debbik away
follow us on social networks because
because you should you should root
internet personalities if you like us
here you will like us more on the other
social media because of the image we
portray exactly online you'll get more
of this through words exactly and photos
just make up your entire identity off
Instagram photos and Twitter post I have
a photo of a banana well that's pretty
accurate you like bananas exactly and
I've got really funny tweets and so do
you don't have funny tweets no but I
tweet out these funny videos yes we're
on a roll